hi
thanks for coming
this talk is about why rust is going to
be a foundational technology to the
future of cloud native infrastructure
before i get to that let me introduce
myself
my name is oliver gould
these are my dogs and i'm the creator of
a project called linkery a service mesh
that's been part of cncf since 2016.
i'm also the cto of a company called
buoyant where we make this and some
other
infrastructure tools
before that i worked at internet
companies like twitter and yahoo really
focused on production operations and
infrastructure and that's really the
lens to which this talk's going to be
delivered
this talks basically three parts first i
want to take you through
a brief history of the cloud from my
perspective
next i want to get into the details of
why i think russ is so important to
cloud technology
and then we'll wrap this up with a quick
tour of the rust toolkit that we use in
linguity
[Music]
so
i want to emphasize this is when we talk
about the history this is the history
from my perspective like all history
subjective
and so if you may have been in the
industry through this whole time you may
have a slightly different perspective of
things that's fine
but i think it's important to set the
table for for where where we've come
from before we talk about where we're
going
so when i entered
the industry when i started working at
yahoo in 2007
yahoo was a big old internet company
they had
literally millions of physical hosts
that were managed and they were managed
by dozens of hardware teams people and
data centers people provisioning
hardware and also dozens of system and
teams so
our team in production operations was
one of many responsible for managing
these hosts these fleet of hosts across
the world
because of this because of all these
legacy systems that accrued over time it
was extremely heterogeneous
lots of freebsd linux creeping in
os versions configurations proliferated
in every different way but the idea here
is that they are largely what they call
pets and not cattle really bespoke
configurations for millions of hosts
uh it also at the time if you wanted to
get hardware
if you wanted a new server
you had to go to something called the
hardware request committee hardware
review committee
and this was literally a meeting with
the cto of the company david philo where
you'd justify your need for a server or
for a fleet of servers and it was
you know undoubtedly slow and laborious
and a little bit stressful to get
hardware
and this was done to save costs and make
sure we're using things efficiently but
it's really a different way of requiring
for getting hardware than we do today
and the first problem i really started
working on there the problem i worked on
through most of my time at yahoo was
config management
so across these millions of hosts
how do we make sure that they get
security patches how do we make sure
that new users of the company get access
to the host or when a user leaves the
company that they no longer have access
to the host how do we manage the
proliferation of configuration
this is a hard problem and we worked on
this for for years
and this wasn't unique to yahoo
lots of companies at the time were going
through similar problems they all had to
manage hosts to be connected to the
internet securely
and so
the proliferation of projects came
around this first cf engine long time
ago written in c
and then
you know in the mid 2000s to late 2000s
we saw new products coming on
mostly in ruby or python projects like
puppet chef ansible and of course others
and the job of a config management
system is
kind of simple a little bit
they mostly have to run commands and
generate templates these scripting
languages that were really coming to
popularity at the time were were good
fit for that they're they're system
scripting languages
and the real job of config management
systems is to make the host able to run
an application and frequently config
management systems were responsible for
actually deploying code for getting
application software ready to run this
meant there's a pretty tight coupling
between your host database and your
actual
application
it's not really where we are today
obviously
around the same time so
early well really throughout the the
early 2000s
we saw a new proliferation of
virtualization technology come online so
projects like freebsd gels kind of in
the earlier side and then
zen and solaris and
building up to linux c groups which so
much of what we're talking about today
is built on
really the job of these virtualization
technologies made
systems multi-tenant so no longer do i
have to have a single host with a single
application or even a single
user or customer
now i can run multiple operating systems
on a single piece of hardware
and this
really really changed the game of course
all this stuff is very low level
operating system that's maybe written in
c at best but also lots of assembly to
get this stuff done because you're
virtualizing hardware you're actually
you know mimicking what a machine does
this gave birth to a new set of products
and services that we really called what
we call the cloud today and it really
made the data center as a service or
data center as a product and ec2 is
probably the first
widely available one of these and of
course in many have followed since
and i remember having a conversation
with a colleague with netflix and
probably 2009 or 2010
where he told me how netflix was moving
from their aix mainframe so netflix
originally was on ax mainframes
uh and how they were moving to aws and
this made no sense to me again i was
working at yahoo
with these
massive fleets of bespoke systems and
the idea that a growing popular internet
company would go to
amazon's infrastructure it didn't make
any sense to me
boy was i wrong huh
so the great thing about this as we all
know
is that it made service accessible
there's no longer a hardware review
committee i have to go to
to get a new server
there's no longer some of the data
center i have to call to get out to fix
a server i
now just have an api and a credit card
and i get access to a server i get an
internet connected server
this means as students we actually can
just get online and get server
technology easily and as startups and
businesses we get access to these things
without having to get data center
contracts or any of the kind of overhead
that's really associated with the time
before this
the other interesting thing here is that
linux is really tied to this right linux
does not generally require licenses to
operate and so this was a great fit i no
longer have to get a microsoft or
whatever license to get
into prod i can now just get a free
operating system and i also no longer
have to worry about the vast array of
driver compatibility issues which were
kind of a headache before this so now i
can just make an api call click a button
and i get a server that's ready to
operate on the internet which is great
it really reduces the barriers to
getting involved in server technology
however
there's some downsides here we're still
dealing with hurt posts even though
we're dealing with virtual hosts vms we
still have hosts as our primary
abstraction which means config
management is still a big problem which
is why we have all these configmatic
companies coming online in projects
we also have no control over the
hardware using very little control of
the hardware we're using which means we
have kind of
less reliability there we don't
no longer are we trying to
have one
superpower machine stay online all the
time now we're kind of dealing in a
world where systems might fail and we
can't call any data center deal with it
we really have to consider variable
variable performance
no longer do i have exclusive access to
a machine i might have
other
you know other businesses running on
this machine that are dealing with lots
of traffic and so these concerns
end up changing how we actually think
about operating services we have a whole
new set of failures
soft failures
more frequent failures and this kind of
gives birth to a new way of testing a
new methodology
called chaos testing also coming out of
netflix probably in 2011 or so
building on that so this is kind of by
the time we met twitter in in 2010
we have a new set of technologies coming
online that really decouple applications
from hosts
so no longer do we as as someone who's
operating a service do i have to think
about config management or ssh into a
host or kind of all the overhead of that
now what we're thinking of through
projects like mesos and aurora are i
just want to ship my workload i want to
write software build an artifact
get it running
and this was really great for twitter
and other
you know growing scaling companies uber
lyft etc
where
you now now need to focus on developer
productivity we have hundreds of
engineers how do we get them to write
software ship it to prod quickly without
having to think about all the
operational overhead how do we stratify
that separate that
the downsides of these projects were
that they're really operationally
complex
it was pretty hard or if not impossible
to run a full mesos cluster on your
laptop
um you actually need quite a bit of
hardware to get started or you need some
pretty beefy cloud boxes to get started
and so there is some overhead here this
is not a broadly accessible technology
that didn't get started with
also we're dealing with a lot of you
know jvm runtime which
comes with runtime costs overhead memory
cpu and operational costs in terms of
debugging gc and things like that
and in this world we're dealing with you
know highly just
highly dynamic systems
where where mesos may reschedule pods or
instances
without there being any kind of user
involvement and so we have to deal with
things like service discovery and load
balancing and retries and timeouts and
all the things that kind of
are necessary to manage services of the
scale
and so twitter we were working on a
library called finagle and that's really
what came to be uh the core of the first
version of linkedin and so
you know as we dealt with all these
production issues and dealt with making
communication more reliable in this
library called finagle the idea with
linker to you as well how do we package
that up into a proxy
and make that accessible to folks who
are not
writing software with finagle
following that or kind of around the
same time there's what the you know a
new set of technologies coming on
that what we call cloud native so it
really kind of starts with docker in a
lot of ways
so docker is building on linux c groups
the technology we're talking about a
little bit ago
and docker makes it possible as many of
you know i'm sure
to package up an application and ship it
somewhere
and get it running
with resource constraints and so it kind
of avoid you know it pulls in parts of
the config management story and isolates
them into a binary that really is almost
a whole operating system running in a
binary
and kubernetes extends that model and
makes it possible to
take a cluster of servers
and just run these docker containers
anywhere
and with that
we have this heavy reliance on the
network
what we call you know microservice
architectures are tiny
services that are distributed in data
center or in a cluster
and they communicate over the network
and so tools like grpc and envoy and
linkerd fit into this world
to really focus on
managing the complexity of a dynamic
system
so we deal with fault tolerance we deal
with the fact that we have to load
balance
and a lot of these things kubernetes and
linkedin especially docker as well
focus on user experience on reducing the
costs of managing it getting started of
understanding it
to make it accessible for application
owners to get running and so we focus on
applications and not hosts you're
finally broken that those barriers down
so let me take a little detour
and describe what lingard is in case you
don't know
and then we'll get into why this is so
important for rust
so lingerie is a service mission what a
service mesh is it's a pattern of
deploying
rich data planes
as generally as a proxy a sidecar proxy
that deal with this communication
complexity and so we have to deal with
load balancing over a set of instances a
set of replicas in a cluster
and i have to deal with making sure that
everything gets tls by default because i
may not trust the network that i'm
running and i also want to have identity
on either side of this i want to know
which workload is talking which workload
and that's easily done through tls
and so what we do is we deploy a proxy
sidecar next to every application
instance
and this helps manage communication and
complexity
this is really in in linguity there's
kind of two halves of this we have a
control plane which talks the kubernetes
api which deals with
a lot of the configuration and discovery
and
the fact that things are dynamic and
feeding that to proxies and the proxies
are supposed to be very lightweight
small
instances that can fit you know many
many many on a host
to this
traffic
and we can kind of look at it like this
right where we have the kubernetes api
kubernetes is of course written and go
and we have a linker d control plane
which is also today where we go
and we chose go for the control plane
because it's so coupled to the
kubernetes api
because we are
we want to use client go we don't want
to have to write a kubernetes client
from scratch and think about all the
complexity of what's in a kubernetes
client and this is again three plus
years ago when we were starting
we wanted lingard's control plane to be
you know feel like part of the
kubernetes ecosystem so we chose go for
that
but when we start went to write the
proxy
the sidecar proxy we chose rust
and that
has been a great experience
um but when we were starting it was
really rough around the edges we had to
bootstrap ourselves we had to build lots
of technology we invest heavily in the
rust ecosystem to make this work
and so why is rust
going to happen now what what about this
moment
meat why is rest so appealing to this
to us in this point of time
well rust gives us a bunch of primitives
to build components right it's a
programming language which which focuses
on safety efficiency and composability
and really on making developers
productive right that
i as an engineer can write a
data plane proxy a you know a micro
service proxy
and i can do that
with high confidence that it's not going
to have memory leaks or
memory safety issues and that will do
the job well
and we want to use this to build the
cloud native technology and so cloud
native systems are again dynamic network
fault tolerant and loosely coupled
and so these
things end up actually aligning pretty
closely and i'm going to get into why
but first let me take you back to the
osi model this is one of my favorite
pictures
every talk i do has this but
we look at the application stack
or the networking stack
and we see all these layers but really
what we're talking about for for
applications for the people building
websites and and user-facing
applications this is how the world looks
they should only really care about
their application logic whether it's
tweets or pictures or payments or
whatever and maybe the presentation
whether that's json or protobuf or you
know the details of how it's
rendered and then shared
but everything beneath that is
infrastructure it's the cloud
but somebody has to build that stuff and
that stuff is us
and so you know down at the bottom we
have physical layers and link layers
which are really you know part of the
cloud providers or or data center or
hardware right and in this middle glue
layer
is where we spend all our time as
infrastructure developers
we built things like lingerie and
kubernetes really fit into this
middle blue layer
that is you know not talked about too
much
this
so what we're all becoming is system
programmers anyone working in the cloud
native space is really not an
application developer applications are
end user facing
system programmers build software that
supports applications
and generally these things have to be
highly trustworthy
meaning that they're going to work
safely and correctly and they're
generally
have
you know pretty tight performance
requirements
and this is really where rust fits in
rust is a native language meaning
reaction compiled a native code we're
not running in a
you know a jit or a runtime a vm
and so we have access to low-level
memory primitives and things like that
but we also need to do that safely and
that's where i think rust really shines
and so i'm going to walk through some
comparisons
i'm going to compare it to go because go
is what i know well and really what is
the kind of state of the art in the
cloud native
and we'll talk about where rust really
makes improvements over the current uh
the current state of things so here's a
really simple example
a function that fails
and i call it
and i ignore the error
this is a great this is a bug right if
something fails we should have to handle
it and russ makes that really easy and
it uses the type system to do that so
one of the big advantages of rust
has a really nice type system and types
let us
express
constraints in a much
richer way and really the goal of all of
what we're doing here is taking things
that might fail
one at runtime when the application's
running and trying to make them fail
before we even build the thing before we
test it as early as possible during the
compilation phase and rust really excels
at this so here
same function that just fails if we
ignore the error
russ will actually emit a compiler
warning in linguity this will prevent
linkery from building and we'll have to
fix this before we go on
another example pretty similar
here is a place where
i access an initialized value and we've
had this type of bug in the linkedin
control plane or cli
countless times more times than i can
character that i that i wish right this
this is a
a big
pain in my neck
um
and russ again makes this simple with a
type system so no longer can i access
something that hasn't been initialized
if i try to do that i'll actually get a
compilation error i have to deal with
the fact that something may not be set
there's no null value and rest
option is the closest thing we have
where it either exists or it doesn't but
it's part of the type system to fix this
i actually
have to
i can get the same thing that same
runtime failure that i would get
and go but i actually have to document
that i have to write expect
with an error message
so no longer just sight faulting because
i did something dumb
rust makes me deal with these things
before i even compile
similarly concurrency becomes a big
issue especially in a proxy like
linkedin's we have multiple connections
and requests going at once we're talking
the control plane there's lots of
concurrent access
and in go this can be quite dangerous by
default so here i've written
just
this actually from the the go by example
website
um where they demonstrate how to use
mutexes and here i've just left the
mutex out and go will happily compile
and it'll even run so if i run this
thing for a second
go works just fine which is great right
unless i run it for longer so i increase
the runtime here to 10 seconds and all
of a sudden i hit an error so this is
completely non-deterministic right i can
write tests that
pass
and then when i ship it to prod this
thing can fail in an unexpected way
this is virtually impossible to do in
rest
so here's the same code effectively
written in rust
and when i try to compile this i'll
actually get an error that says hey this
map you built
you can't use it multiple places at once
somebody has to own this thing and so
this idea of a borrower checker is
really an ownership model for who owns
memory who is responsible for this
or what code is responsible for this
means that i can't even compile this
code in rest because i it's unsafe
the axis patterns aren't safe
and so to fix this i actually have to go
and put a mutex in this is the same fix
effectively that should exist in the go
code but the compiler enforces it rest
when i add the mutex everything works
pop as you'd expect
which is great the rust has made my
program more safe
without even
writing tests
my last example here is that rust is
this idea called
uh raii resource acquisition is
initialization and this deals with
lifetimes and when um kind of tying back
to that borrowing and ownership model
and once i drop something it no longer
exists
and so here
in the example on the left we have go
code
and that
sends two messages on a channel and then
drops the sender and then i have another
task that continually reads from that
channel
and if i run this it runs until that
error happens and we hit a deadlock and
go
exits which is great i mean go should
fail in this case
because that's the best it can do but we
can do better in rust
and rust i have this type system again
and what the type system tells lets me
do is i get an optional value back and
so there's no more runtime failure here
i can't even write the code
to not work here i have to handle these
conditions and when i do that
i actually uh
we see that we get a some value back
every time we do a read
so this is an example of the type of
safety net that we get from rust and why
you know we haven't even gotten to any
of the details around memory access or
you know rus kind of provable safety but
these are all sorts of ways that we take
failures that could happen at runtime
after i've shipped my software to
production when i hit a weird corner
case where things can crash and break
the whole up you know the rest of the
system
russ we want to push all ruts russ lets
us take all of those types of failures
and bring them back in the development
cycle so they have to be dealt with
explicitly
and finally let me take you through a
quick tour of what of tokyo's async
ecosystem the tokyo is a rust library
that's kind of similar to neti if you're
familiar with the jvm because it gives
us asynchronous i o
and so when i when i start a program i
set up the tokyo runtime and this lets
us run
io concurrently without having to have a
thread per connection or you know it
gives us something you can basically
think of similar to goes runtime where
go has these green threads that let you
run things concurrently and just block
uh rust in tokyo give you kind of a
similar set of primitives and tokyo has
an ecosystem around it that really lets
us
build up
a new technique build up systems on
these good primitives that are
trustworthy
the first one which we've invested
heavily in linkedin a lot of the towers
primitives come out of linkerd is this
system called tower which is really
similar to finagle's services and so
it's a service abstraction where there's
a request and a response
and a set of you know layers or
middlewares that'll let us
layer stack these things together so
they can be used and i can write
loosely coupled components and then
bind them together so here's an example
from the linker d
proxy this is an http client
and so what this is for every endpoint
we're talking to we build one of these
services and this has an http client it
has a reconnect layer
it lets us do linkery's tab feature and
adds metrics and all of these compo all
of these features are
you know
orthogonal they have no dependencies on
each other really
um
and so i can write all of these separate
modules that are easily tested or easily
shared and reused
without having to
couple them together
this is a really great building block
i also
should emphasize that a lot of the
primitives we've developed for linkerity
are freely available in the tower uh
library and framework um
that so you can use for instance
linkedin's load balancer
without having to uh pull in linkedin
that's that's a you know the tower
balance project or
crate
is um
something we've contributed back
upstream
so this is a again a set of reusable
components that you can use to build new
systems
another library that we've been heavily
involved this is something called tonic
the tonic is a grpc
binding for rust
again cup
really bound up with
tower and tokyo's async runtime async
networking
tonic lets me write little grpc services
so here on the right this is a load
testing service that i wrote
and we just have to implement
you know we take a
a grpc protobuf and we write the
function
that
generated by that api and now we have a
network server and so this makes it
really easy to build microservices or
little pieces of services in rust
again with tokyo's async runtime
finally i
i want to call out
another library which is newer in this
ecosystem called kubar s
and kubrs
is basically client go
for rust
but it's
uh so what it gives us is
kubernetes api bindings and primitives
that use
the tokyo primitives that use that can
be
merged easily with tonic grpc services
or tower services
and so here is an example from a
prototype i'm building
which uh watches all pods in a cluster
and it indexes which ports are available
on those pods
so this is something i'm really excited
about because this means we may actually
start
being able to replace or
as we add new controllers in linguity we
can start doing them in rust where
several years ago this was totally not
possible
now we have a rich ecosystem of products
around rust and around tokyo
specifically that we can use to stamp
out
new infrastructure code that is going to
be much safer that we're going to get
more we'll be more productive writing
and generally
have a much easier time about it
so in summary
cloud computing creates new ubiquitous
abstractions
no longer have to deal with managing
hosts or acquiring hardware nearly the
same way that we did a decade ago
now we have
kubernetes apis and we we have lots of
glue beneath the application and we need
that to work well
we've all become system programmers
anyone who would have been in operations
a decade ago is basically a systems
programmer now
but
scaling that out having to have
you know an industry of people right in
the sea
would not be great it hasn't been great
we have security vulnerabilities we have
safety issues and
we actually have you know c has a pretty
steep learning and development curve
and rust makes this way more accessible
and one of the things i'm most excited
about in the rust ecosystem
is the number of young engineers getting
involved here
people in school or just out of school
are really gravitating towards rust and
i think that
the industry is going to be transformed
by this we're going to have a
much
richer more reliable
systems ecosystem that's built on rust
finally this wasn't possible a few years
ago there's been a tremendous amount of
investment
our team has invested heavily in rust
and these ecosystem libraries
uh folks at amazon and microsoft google
you name it uh have have been investing
in rust and i think that this really
paints to a future
that is going to be much safer
more efficient better for the
environment and more reliable
and so finally thanks for coming i hope
this talk was useful
i hope you enjoy the rest of the talks
today
have a good one